[Music]
if you caught my direct message last
week you heard me explain why we
shouldn't let politics make us crazy yet
the crazy seems to be ramping up
everywhere you look these days
this constant onslaught of political
bickering has an incredibly polarizing
effect on most people
the fighting either makes them
obsessively tuned into politics non-stop
or reflexively tune out of politics
altogether with so much news and
commentary content out there if you give
me an hour or two of your week to hear
about political science philosophy
religion or anything else we're
discussing here I consider the time you
spend with me to be a pretty high honor
those of you who follow me on social
media outside of YouTube probably saw
that I spent last week on a farm with
family and friends outside of Seattle
though I spend most of the week hanging
out with 20 chickens and one duck who
thinks she's a chicken I had a couple
personal experiences with actual
real-life human beings which reminded me
why these aren't just abstract ideas
that we talked about here one of the
people on the farm with us was a trans
woman in her 20s who happened to grow up
on a pot farm she was also an avid
hunter and a guns rights enthusiast who
was painting her gun rocker bright blue
and pink at the time of our visit yes
trans women are sometimes into guns but
if you judge people as a collective
instead of as an individual this is
exactly the type of person who will
always go ignored I also spend some time
with a farmer who lived almost a hundred
percent off his own land but he was very
concerned with treating other people
fairly and making sure that others had
the same opportunity to succeed which he
had while his day to day life had a very
libertarian bent it because he provided
for himself and was living off the land
there was no doubt that he wanted there
to be assistance for people so that they
could one day share in the same
opportunity and pride in work that he
himself had attained his live and let
live attitude was blended with his
desire to do good for others in his
community he was a far cry from what
some would say about those selfish
libertarians or what others might say
about those authoritarian left
while I was away I also had a truly
awe-inspiring hike up Mount Rainier
which is part of the US National Park
Service this park is an incredible
example of a natural wonder that we have
right here in this country which happens
to be funded and protected by the
federal government you guys all know
that I'm a small government guy and I'd
always prefer local and state funding
but a place like Mount Rainier which is
so gorgeous and so powerful I believe
should have some federal funding and I'd
say the same by the way for a place like
Yellowstone National Park or Yosemite
the question here is how much funding or
the best way to pay for this funding
that's really what the debate is about
by the way Mount Rainier is also funded
by state and local organizations and I
met many great people along the trail
who are volunteering their time and
energy to a place they love so much that
right there is called putting your
beliefs into action not just demanding
that the government pay for something
with other people's money which is often
what we talk about my point here is that
people are complex issues are complex
and finding answers which will satisfy
everyone almost always is absolutely
impossible at the same time not only do
we all have our own strengths and
passions but we all also have our own
inconsistencies and blind spots
our goal shouldn't be about purity tests
so that people fall in line or adhere to
some false notion of perfection our goal
should be the acknowledgement of
differences so we stand up for the
freedom and for the Liberty that this
country was founded upon
[Music]
joining me today is an author a
commentator a screenwriter and a pilot
oh well welcome to the Reuben report
good to be here did took long enough
it didn't take long during the distance
we had to travel to get here I had no
idea I don't want to give it anything
away related to our location we will not
be we are 2 unto 2 undisclosed locations
that are probably 400 yards apart from
each other something like yeah
completely ridiculous there is a food
place which we're not going to describe
where later we could possibly break
bread sweet would necessarily be bread
we were breaking there it would be what
careful I don't want to say anything
else all right I'm looking forward to
talking to you I was on your show a
couple weeks ago we have a great a great
discussion about the things that I
really care about about freedom about
Liberty about how we should be governed
about ways that we shouldn't be governed
and all sorts other stuff and especially
about the idea that people should not
only should be allowed to but but the
entire thesis of this country is
disagreement right and that's the entire
reason we're here should be able to
discuss things I think I said on the
show and I'd certainly mean it when
somebody makes a case that's compelling
enough for me I'll change my mind that
feels bigger personally I feel I feel
like I come out of that larger yes
alright so let's start right there what
happened what went wrong seemingly in
the last couple years we're sitting down
from someone that you disagree with and
agreeing to disagree or just not
agreeing to disagree but going okay I
can still win the country with that
person what where did that go where did
that start crumbling when did exact or
first of all I think I think there's you
could probably make the case that in
terms of what the other side doesn't
like you kind of started this pendulum
and rather than the pendulum damping out
has just gotten wider and wider and
wider right so so you know there's a
there's Reagan and we didn't like Reagan
so Bill Clinton could serve as didn't
like Clinton even George Bush and live
with her and then Barack Obama and now
Donald Trump is just things just get a
building's going to come apart but I
think the primary thing that's changed
is that politics is in so much more of
our life than it used to be seems to me
that I didn't know I didn't know if my
dad was a Republican or Democrats I was
probably 23 18 19 20 I just did he care
and I didn't think about politics in any
way shape or form until I was
forty-three so all of all of the things
that used to be political we're not
things that you get particularly ginned
up about you know somebody's going to
make a trade agreement with China and if
your neighbor thinks it should be 13%
you know one of the 24% people you're
not likely to lose Thanksgiving dinners
over those things right but as politics
is pressed itself out into everything
else in the entire culture now
everything is political and you find
yourself on these on these sides of
issues and sometimes occasionally you
find yourself arguing against things
that you actually kind of support just
because you know what's coming from the
other team and as it's getting really
out of hand
yeah so you were political know you were
43 yeah which is really fascinating and
I want to get to that but that you
didn't know that whether your father was
a Democrat or Republican is kind of
interesting tell you a little bit about
growing up well my dad was a hotel
manager is born in Manhattan and we live
just across river in in West New York
just a couple of yards from where Aaron
Burr one night all right and just before
my first birthday we moved to Bermuda so
I grew up in Bermuda and I actually kind
of grew up in the best corner of a meter
my dad was pretty solidly middle class I
don't think I was quite shocked as a
novel when I found out he never made
more than forty four thousand dollars he
really is really quite a shock for me
but there were a lot of great perks with
it and growing up on that pink beaches
of Bermuda was pretty nice but the main
thing about that experience was the
British schools which are more anyway
exceptional extraordinary they were
highly disciplined very structured but
they were also very competitive very
competitive and I just took to that and
and it gave me a four or five year boost
in terms of education but socially it
was probably a five year anchoring
recipe I was all very school so suddenly
you arrived in Miami and you're fearing
for your life you had this funny accent
you don't carry your book right you know
and yes so so it was it was a real
transformative experience for me and
then what took you another 23 years to
get into politics well I I had seen
birds but my dad was very busy man
because a hotel manager is a day job and
a night job run the hotel during the day
came home take an hour to nap and then
go down and entertain the guests so he
took me to see the Thunderbirds out at
Kenley Air Force Base in 65 I guess
flying up one hundreds and I just
dropped my ice cream cone I never really
pick it up you know I mean honestly
what so between ages of five and 17 I
was just I was just going to go I was
going to be an astronaut I was serious
about it I got a job at the Miami
planetarium when I was 13 I think and I
was running shows and teaching astronomy
there from 14 and everything's looking
good and I want to take the vision test
as part of the physical sail through
everything else indeed even though I had
a vision problem Wow until I failed the
vision test and that was it that was it
and needless to say I spent that summer
between junior and senior year in
college just wandering around like a
somebody been clubbed on the head you
know I didn't leave the house for well
yeah that must be I mean I didn't know
exactly what I always tell you I see I
sometimes still I don't know exactly
what I want to do but I can only imagine
being what's at 17 today that's right
and and suddenly your dreams are crushed
by something that you simply cannot
control yeah and I've been after these
for quite a long time but that that's
exactly and by the way that's a really
interesting point because that aspect of
my life has been a big influence on a
lot of the political thinking I do that
that idea that you know that that nobody
that the world did not owe me the Air
Force Academy the world didn't only Mars
mission all the things I thought I was
going to do it didn't owe those things
to me I was heartbroken by it but that's
the way it goes and and parenthetically
just very quickly what I did find out
about life is that you know you can't
always get what you want but sometimes
you know try real hard you can get what
you need so so I don't think there's a
song about that not suspect that maybe I
do not I'm certainly I'm quite certain I
came up with it um but but so I you know
I wanted to fly f-16s and I can't fly
f-16 that I never will but I have a
little experimental airplane with a
propeller in the back so I don't have to
see it and I go through the air at 200
miles an hour and I make my fighter
pilot turns and and it's good enough so
that is the pilot that I
yeah that's a big part of my personality
and but it's a really interesting point
for me because there's very few people
in life I think get exactly what they
want but if you are dealt cards that
prevents that you can still get pretty
close I know that I mean the number of
people playing NBA basketball as a
percentage of population as you can see
where I would rather be than here
exactly probably the only place that
here would be if I could be in the NBA
okay so you don't get a chance to play
in the NBA and that's the card you're
dealt with and there's nothing you can
do about that but you do get to play
basketball and if you really really like
playing basketball you could play league
basketball with guys that are really
really good and it's it's it's enough it
is for me anyway yeah yeah well that's
what it's all about right sort of going
as hard as you can but then realizing
where the limits might be and then
figuring out how to max that out
whatever that means do you enjoy and
skill or yeah I I learned very late also
probably only three or four years ago
somebody told me that the that the
ancient Greek definition of happiness
was using all of your abilities to their
fullest and I thought that's really true
yeah you know you know you know when
you're doing good work and you know when
you're doing bad work but you know when
you're doing good work and when you do
things that that you put a lot of effort
into and especially when you work really
hard for four goals for a long period of
time it's there's no feeling like it
it's the reason the reason them makes me
feel human yeah that would be a good
segue to where I want to go in a little
bit about you know building your own
thing and having your own platform and
doing this on your own outside of
mainstream we're going to get there but
I want to hear about this forty
three-year-old episode what happened
you're 43 years old yeah you're doing
your thing well because suddenly well
the air force thing happened between my
junior and senior year in college and I
had some friends basically took pity on
me and they dragged me out into the
Florida summer and we started making
super 8 movies and it gave me a chance
to a little clowning around and I guess
it's just a natural Hammond does and
stuff certainly looking at most of my
videos I realize that's probably putting
it mildly yeah but it was actually fun
and and we took it real seriously we did
we did a lot of story
and cuts and you know we didn't just
turn on again we took it like real
movies and then I realized that when I
went for my senior year in high school
that all all the girls who had who had
wanted nothing to do with mr. calculator
on his belt turtleneck in the Florida
summer you know there's a science dork
yeah all of a sudden they're making
movies everybody wants to be in them you
know and you're getting invited to
parties and people should and you're
actually kind of funny it's again
putting last year too and and so there
was that we would turtleneck and flour
if you have no idea don't even calculate
it don't even start me it's all part of
the it's all part of the outer shell of
vanity that that makes my life what it
is but but but truthfully I mean it was
it was a when I say was a role it was an
identity and and it was very important
to me and then I became a theater major
at the University of Florida friend of
mine who's a year older who was baking
the movies just goofing around one tuna
versa Florida got a degree theater he
said you can come up spend a weekend
with the mist you can actually do this
for he couldn't agree in this yeah
you're financially well damn you know so
I was a theater major and I was very
left-wing I would say very left-wing and
over time I just I just started reading
all kinds of other different things and
it never was really a moment so I was I
was considered a Republican by the
people I was working with but I didn't
know much about anything 9/11 turned a
lot of people but it didn't turn me what
turned me was right after 9/11 about
nine months later my dad died and he was
interred at Arlington which is shocked
because he was never a war hero he's
never shot at he got the Germany in the
last week of the war I think but I found
myself out there on an October morning
I've never been that cold in my life and
and you're walking the Rose Barrington
and all of the headstones are exactly
the same and here's a major-general he's
been in you know world war one world war
two Korea Vietnam golfing horn here's a
guy who just do the math he's a sergeant
he was in less than a year maybe and
this was in October of 2002 when a lot
of the push back was starting all we
deserved 9/11 it was our fault you know
and I just remember thinking that my dad
who had been such a such an asset as a
businessman
over time we just face
we get fired on the phone but 40 40 some
years after he signed on the dotted line
along with everybody else you know they
turn out here's 20 guys in the army band
here's another 20 guys in the army honor
guard and the caisson and everything
it's freezing cold these guys are at
attention they're the same age as he was
when he sign on the dotted line and I
thought a country that keeps its
promises like that that keeps those
fundamental promises is is worth
defending
so I I wrote a just a very brief
two-page thing to a guy whose blog I
admired very much at the time guy named
Stephen dead best and he said you mind
if I print this in a picture and got a
lot of attention and it's something else
I got attention and Rachel Lucas set me
up with a with a blog and I started a
blog called eject eject eject and I
didn't write about politics at all I
wrote about philosophy and I wrote about
morality I wrote got to be an I guess
but I wrote as is called am courage and
responsibility power honor freedom
history those kind of things yeah any
learning issues it's interesting to me
because when I was on your show just a
couple weeks ago we did we did a full
hour and there we didn't prepare before
you even question me before but I knew
that you know we've met a couple times
and I knew that we're you know we have a
good conversation but we barely talked
politics in the traditional sense when I
get a little more of this where we're
talking about the ideas around politics
that sort of frame it that's that's
always what I'm interested in that I
sense that's what you're interested in
so why is that why isn't it about the
minutiae there's so many people lost I
think in the minutiae of the day-to-day
politics screaming about this immediate
decision or Trump tweeted this today
very active reaction yeah exactly the
reaction to this I find the only way to
make sense of it is to try to care about
the stuff that really is the
underpinning of it absolutely right and
and one of the reasons I was looking
forward to coming here and talking to
you and we did the election night thing
as well is because there's a great deal
that civility GONOW people can make a
legitimate claim that you know I'm
advancing the laws of civility because I
do a fair number of
of videos where I point out things that
I don't think Thanks just doin about
flyover I got a pretty good job but yeah
over in mine are they big I think they
called it they knew I was going to be on
her Thunderbird story you guys are four
and a half minutes late but they it's
it's about the philosophy and it's about
the ability to disagree about things and
and to be honest with you I'm ready to
talk to anybody who's ready to make an
argument you know and not just launch
all the vitriol but but I I try very
very very hard to get things right
and before I ever go on camera or do
anything I really do kind of preflight
these ideas I kind of walk around so
what if you wrong me right about this
you know are you are you are you
cherry-picking data are you aware that
you might be cherry-picking data without
even knowing it and if I make a spelling
mistake it makes me sick you know it
just it just makes me ill yeah one of
the things that we talked about a couple
weeks ago is that I said to you that
I've never blamed me lied on this show
that's right I have made mistakes right
without question we've had times where
I've made a mistake and I told my guys
after leave it in because I want I'll
comment that in the comments and even
say you know I screwed this up yeah but
I want people to see that I'm as human
as anyone else and anything but I would
never intentionally mislead or
intentionally lie but even that that
seems like such a big thing these days
when it's actually such a small thing
yeah and that's probably but most the
single most common word applied to
people in in terms of criticism of their
politics on YouTube comments or whatever
you know liar this is a lie lie lie lie
lie I can honestly stand here and tell
you same as you I have never told a lie
on those shows that doesn't mean I've
never been wrong but it means I have
never gone out there knowing something
was untrue and said it as if it was true
yeah that goes to so much of what's
wrong with mainstream media right now
which I know you're we're very much
simpatico on that a lot of the
mainstream media stuff so the night that
we first met was election i we were over
the Daily wire offices and they had some
beers and Shapiro was there and Clavin a
couple other guys Shapiro was sort of
vacillating back and forth between he
was thrilled that Hillary wasn't going
to be President but sort of
horrified the Trump was my bread I
thought it was vacillating between being
really upset the Trump want and being a
little bit upset the Trump won but but
yeah he was here after he was out here
vibrating however you want to party I
had never seen him in that position
before Clavin I think with a little and
I had him out a couple weeks ago he was
more okay with Trump but you were you
were elated that man and you were the
first person that I saw and it was
because it was happening that night and
I happened to be in a room with you you
were the first person that I saw that
was like this is this is it this is what
I've wanted like you know a night had
Milo on in Serna [ __ ] and Scott Adams
other supporters but I happened to be
with you that night are you are you as
elated eight months later well I am but
but probably almost certainly for
reasons that you that you don't suspect
I wasn't elated that Donald Trump was
elected because I was a Donald Trump in
I was never a Donald Trump fan when
people asked me for the first six months
of this thing what do you like about say
one thing I like about Donald Trump I
like his had you know I've pretty much
it and all throughout the debates and so
on and and and so I was never like a
Trump guy was I was a real solid you
know I was I was a Ted Cruz guy mm-hmm
but I wasn't elated about the night
because Donald Trump won I was elated
about the night because there was still
room for choice in the American
political system that this thing was not
on a rail that this media bias was not
something that was insurmountable there
still was a chance to get off of the
track of history that had been written
out for for pretty much the whole
country I don't think it was going to
win I didn't think it was going to win
it all and the main reason I was as
happy as I was to be honest with you is
is because uh my fiancee is from Russia
and when she cannot well the fiance is
oh is it open when she came over here
cher yeah but when she did this before
the Russian thing happen because that'll
happen post-election to two nights after
the election Hillary says fake news
Russian connection all arrested but she
came over from Russia and and we went to
a debate watching the first debate with
a bunch of conservatives here in Los
Angeles there were three of us I suspect
maybe Johnny twenty Twenty twenty five
bingo
and in that first debate Trump was
landing these these bees let's not say
he was landing any blows but he was
counter-attacking with enthusiasm let's
at least put it that way and people were
cheering and and she looked at me and
said why is everybody so excited as
honey bees are these are important
issues this is really really important
and it was impossible for her to really
realize on the spot that we take it as
wheat that we that there is in fact a
choice there's no politics in Russia
right the people don't have any middle
talk politics in Russia because it
doesn't make any difference what your
politics are in Russia poop is going to
do what he wants to do and that's the
way it is the idea that people would
have an emotional vested interest in the
outcome of this meant but the outcome
was in doubt and and as the as the
primary went on and as the rather as the
rest of the election season went on and
so on it just began to look like that
kind of headwind was just insurmountable
that the Clinton you know the Clinton
machine and and and and the immediate
coverage and everything was just not
going to be possible but no he was never
my kid he's not my candidate now he is
he is to me the only person that is
capable of destroying the the media
information complex and what comes with
that I'll take and it's so interesting
that so many people are putting such a
high premium on that including Andrew
Clavin who we were with that night and
one of the things that he said that
evening that did help me frame this a
little bit more was he said what a
beautiful country we live in that all
the pundits could be wrong yeah all of
the the money and the power in the elite
they all said this is going to happen
all the polls said this is going to
happen and the reverse happened that
actually shows you the strength of our
democracy and the beauty of the power to
the people absolutely right and this is
my entire theory of what what I try to
defend is I had when I was in my 20s and
30s certainly right after I started
making movies and stuff in colleges in
college
I was exceedingly unpleasant person I
really was I was so I was so obsessed
with intelligence I was so obsessed with
you know looking smart being smart and
and I was so sure of myself and I had
that beaten out of me over the course of
you know 25 30 years 30-plus years of
being a limo driver a security guard
waiter you know all these things and I
got to I got to be in show business I
came out here as an editor and I'm
hanging around very you know
sophisticated people and very beautiful
people and some celebrities and things
like that and when I'm speaking event
early in my career and I'll just tell
you the story straight up I was at an
event afterwards I make it a point to be
the last person out of the room you know
they're going to fly me out there and
people going to come and see me I'm the
last guy out so I was talking to
everybody and and a guy came up to me
and honest to god he looked like junior
samples from he you know he's a big guy
he was wearing the the the overalls you
know the coveralls and he just he looked
like junior samples from hee haw and I
had this thought right right then I
thought you know it'd be nice if I was a
you know if I was a leftist and I could
get all this kind of you know more
glamorous people in Hollywood crowd in
the hole I just flow with the entire pop
culture and then right on the heels of
that wasn't later anything just like
this lightning bolt like I'd shocked
myself
you know I remember thinking dude this
man knows a hundred things more than you
do
better than you hundred things he knows
better than you do and there's probably
two or three things that this guy's
knows that make him pretty near an
expert in the world now that may be just
things like at what temperature milk
because the congeal or whatever but
don't don't go there
this was an enormous breakthrough for me
and and it's been something I've tried
to keep myself honest with very very
long time and very carefully it's the
idea that there is a reservoir of
knowledge in the population of America
and that it's not based entirely on
education fact it's not based mostly on
education it is a fundamental decency
and a fundamental sense of what works
and what doesn't and I got tired of
those people being demonized I got tired
of them being
being assaulted by people with very high
rhetorical skill and and very
good-looking on camera and very big love
loudspeakers but I got tired of it and
it doesn't strike me as fair and and I
and I what I learned from this Dave is I
learned that rhetorical ease and
intelligence are not the same thing
they look like they're the same thing to
some people but they're not the same
thing they're different yeah that's so
interesting to me because we both were
born in New York we both now live in LA
and yet I feel what you're saying very
intimately that always became obvious to
me when I started interviewing people I
start getting emails from people in the
middle of the country and they say David
doesn't sound like you're judging us
everyone else is judging us I was
thinking I don't think I'm better than
you I'm somebody just doing the best I
can
there you go and that's it okay that's
it I hope I'm bringing some goodness
here and try and do the best I can but
but I don't feel that I have some magic
wisdom that they don't have I think if
anything they might have some magic with
them that I don't have cisely right
which is why which is why my favorite
part of the speaking events is the Q&A
because ivory I love the cave I Clark
yeah first of all if you can get a
question you've never heard before and
you can answer it on the fly yeah that
means you understand your philosophy
because many questions you've dealt with
before so you have kind of a canned
answer it's the only way to think about
you yeah comedian you write jokes for a
musician sing song if you're funded you
have answers to things that you get a
lot but but when I get a question that I
literally stumps me I realize for me
person I say well what's the freedom
answer here what's what is the freedom
answer here and that almost always takes
me to the right place and so I enjoy
that aspect of it but I learned so much
from the people and one of the things
that I learn a lot from I don't do many
of them just haven't but when I go to
very liberal schools I have a very steep
learning curve as a result of my
interaction with the audience which is
important and I suspect you probably
enjoy and I do I'm not wired for
patience as a general rule but I hadn't
experienced out
East Texas this just last winter and I
got to this event and I started speaking
and I think I might have mentioned we
did a whole segment on this matter of
fact and there's a guy in the front row
who had started a Facebook page to have
me banned from certain area yeah and I
said if you know if you imagine if
Trotsky and growing up in Malibu that's
what this guy looked like so Malibu
Trotsky yelling over I mean I'm using
yelling over everything I'm trying to
say and to my absolute astonishment
I just got serene I mean I like past
comment just kind of the Zen tranquility
you know and and I just let him go and
let him go and go and go and go and go
and go and people would ask me questions
a lot of antagonism about the questions
and I'd start asking people about trying
to find what we have in common maybe
agreeing maybe nodding and I think
Malibu Trotsky looked around and said
well he's actually having a conversation
with these people that I brought down to
boo him off the stage and then he
started criticizing me you and your
epilogue answers you know what is it
with all these long Asia you and your
explanations for your behavior it's the
the big breakthrough for me and I in
from from the time I've been doing
progressive events I don't do many of
them probably done six or seven colleges
is that I thought I would go in there
and I thought that my mission doing it I
don't think I changing but he's mind but
I thought at the very least my mission
is to go in there and explain these
principles in such a way that people can
understand them just give it to them the
way it is not not the way people tell
them I don't tell them what I think not
not let them hear what other people
think that I think but I found out very
early in all of these cases that my
primary result was that by the time was
over people said well he strikes me as a
human being anyway you know he strikes
me as a human being he's a conservative
so obviously he wants to see poor people
just dying in the gutter but he strikes
me as a person who doesn't want to see
people dying in the gutter and turns out
I don't
and so this moral preening that causes
test traffic events downstream is the
one thing that I have genuine hatred for
is when people will will puff themselves
up about taking a position
that's one thing but when you pup
yourself up about all the good you're
doing when in point of fact the
downstream effects that are catastrophic
murderous ruinous dead people ruin lives
and you don't want to look at that you
want to you want to instead just have a
good feeling of feeling like you're
doing the right thing
that's when I get religion yeah well
that's what is perfect way to end that
sentence because it's an odd moral
position that they've put themselves in
the same way you know we've said this on
the show a bunch lately but this this
progressivism has become a secular
religion in a lot of respects and
uncoupling that or at least dealing with
those people can be tough and I think
maybe we're you've probably made some
headway and I think where I've made a
little bit of headway is that if you
keep pushing the ideas of what I'm for
your Liberty I'm for your freedom I'm
for you to live your life the way you
want but then that comes with having
other people live their lives the way
they want I think you can get a little
headway there but but it is tough it is
tough for sure well fortunately
recording this so you can take this out
in post if you want to I don't want to
hate nothing you know I don't want to
out you here but I mean I look over to
the control room and there's in America
there's an American flag and I got a big
American for Americans like that's
vintage for like you know a lot of
beautiful things but here's what that
tells me
seeing that flag in the background tells
me that you love this country and that
you care about this country and that you
would like for the citizens of this
country to have the most optimal
outcomes they possibly can what how we
get there is the subject of discussion
paralyzer but your motivation from my
value said your motivation is is the
same as my motivation so I don't so I
could talk to you all day about all
kinds of things and not ever get heated
about it because I could get excited
about it but never angry about it
because I proceed your motivations to be
the same as mine and I try with all my
might to make sure that my motivations
are are worthy you know that they're
that they're decent motivations that
there but they're not selfish or they're
not exclusionary or they're not any of
these things they're they're the things
that you could answer for and and not
have to blush you know so you're telling
me that as a Republican and someone on
the right you're not an evil racist
bigoted homophobic llama bulb give me a
couple other photo of arachnophobia I
made the case before
I'll just give it to you as an example
here I genuinely think I I was one of
the things they yelled at me a lot about
it and that university was that it said
that black lives matter is not a serious
movement and that I cared more about
black people's lives and the black lives
matter people do now that's a
provocative statement I understand that
but the data for 2014 shows the total
number of black homicides in the country
up the total number of blacks killed in
this country in 2014 four percent were
by policemen under any circumstances
it's not four percent of the hands up
that's four percent shooting a police
officer death death by police officers
four percent and when you have a
political movement that is that is
determined to make not it's not just
making a Mulville out of the four
percent because there there is some
signal in there there are some bad cops
so that that's a legitimate point that
needs to be raised but when when
everything you do is about this four
percent of your problem and ninety-six
percent of the problem you're not only
ignoring you're suppressing when
somebody points out the fact hey you
know you're putting all this effort
under 4% most of which is not even up
for discussion you know it's a gun fight
or something and you're leaving 96
percent out here that tells me you're
not a serious movement and I want to
know why and then you look at things
like Detroit's been governed by
Democrats uninterrupted mayors and City
Council's for 60 years Atlanta's like
138 years something like this you it
takes courage and I don't mean to blow
myself up over this it takes courage to
say that if somebody has to point this
out that somebody has to point out where
the problem really is and I know what's
coming for me when I say that you know I
know it but it has to be said because
people are getting children they're not
getting killed where we live here in
Santa Monica uh or run yeah I'm where
this is not where the problem is yeah
it's easy to talk about these things and
it's easy to put a bumper sticker on
your car and hold up a sign and purchase
all the rest of it but meanwhile every
week in Chicago five or six people are
being killed they're mostly black people
they're being killed because of these
policies are being killed because of all
of the economic decay all the graft all
the corruption all of it the people
dying 100
them every year in every one of these
major cities and that's not an accident
and it's not a coincidence so okay so I
get it so you're you're you're putting
your ass on the line I mean that'sthat's
what any of us that are really like to
take unpopular positions do so you're
you're putting your butt on the line to
say something like that when you've made
headway with people have you been able
to get someone to go wait a minute that
if Atlanta has had Democratic mayor's
for X amount of years or Chicago or
wherever and this is where all this
crime and murder is happening this is
where people are not moving upward and
all that how have you been able to reach
people on that because it because it
seems like it's almost like it's almost
the reverse and reason in a way because
people are just they just hold that
belief they just hold a belief that
somehow it's the evil Republicans or
something better that are doing this
this is the racist some of but let me
let me just go just a slightly up to the
sides that because I think the best way
to answer that is is like this when I
realized that people wanted to read what
I was writing was just on a blog and
stuff and when I started to do actual
political commentary it became clear to
me pretty early that I thought my job
was to change people's minds was to
convince them of things but very quickly
after having gone to a bunch of speaking
events I think this is different for
conservatives and industry liberals I
realized that a requirement that
superseded changing people's minds was I
had to I had to pass ammunition to
people who and and not just ammunition
but comfort to people who've been under
fire for a long time that that my
primary job was was to was to remind
people that we call conservatives in the
country today that they're not nuts that
they're not evil that they're not all of
these things and provide the evidence
that that is the case so I realized
early that while it would have been nice
to be a diplomat mostly my job was to go
up and down the line and hand out
ammunition cartridges you know and and
and stop people from being so filled
with despair because I don't think it's
accidental but even if it is one of the
things that is applied against
conservatives is this cultural idea that
you're a dinosaur and you're all these
horrible amoral things and that's the
entire purpose because if we start
arguing you know you're
so there are a lot of people out there
and and what becomin I was getting we're
not so much you changed my mind but bill
you finally put words into what I've
been feeling my whole life and you
finally allow me to talk to somebody at
the you know the water cooler or
whatever you've given me the arguments I
knew these things were true I just
didn't know how to express them and that
that became my primary motivation now if
that is your motivation you're going to
take a different rhetorical tack than
you are if you're actually going to try
and convert people and I would like to
be in converting people mode but I felt
that I felt that that the less made of
the same kind of ridicule that the right
has been getting the whole time and
because I'm a former I was never what
you'd call a progressive biting it's
always about the country military
business owners would but I my first
vote was from Walter Mondale Wow
and it was because he said he was gonna
raise taxes huh yeah so you've come
you've come a long way so to speak and
and this is not an effort to indicate
that people who don't hope my positions
are wrong but I can tell you what
interests me the most is I cannot
believe looking back on things how
passionately I believed in things that I
knew nothing about nothing
yeah that's almost the key to being
really passionate about things really
well I don't know that much about it I
think that's not true either affected as
you've gotten as you've gotten more
experience in more enlightened me too I
find that the truth that the pachinko
balls of events tend to fall where
they're where you expect them to fall
and I personally now this is more of a
conservative statement but I personally
like the ability to say one thing and
then do the same thing I don't have to
call for higher taxes and until my
accountant to take every deduction that
he possibly needs you know I don't have
to do any of that right and right you're
saying that probably will most
progressives are just human what most
celebrities are doing I mean Matt Damon
says oh we should raise taxes and I'm
rich I'll pay the highest percentage of
taxes ok Matt but first of all you
instead of going on with 13 you know you
go home with 10 but there are people are
struggling and so on and you're pretty
much we know you're going into your
accounting paying of course I but Matt I
know I knew
they don't know that that paramount
doesn't write a check pay to the order
of Matt Damon 12 million dollars they
write a check that says pay to MD
Enterprises LLC right
12 million dollars and then the business
pays for your house your car all your
travel everything they give you enough
money to you know to go grocery shopping
on and so on then you pay tax on that
yeah and so this is the essence of it I
just like you don't have a problem with
that actually I don't have a table with
the hypocrisy not exactly no no no for
us of course I don't have a problem with
that at all yeah they're taking about
half of what I make half and and here's
the thing and this is very enlightening
having Sibylla very much from Russia
because Natasha would say to me she
watched me write these checks to the IRS
saying what are you getting so what you
mean well in Russia we have free health
care we have free college we have free
housing basically all these things paid
for by the state and they take 25% of
what we make and I was a little
embarrassed out of it but what what the
kind of things that really affect me are
I try to put myself in other people's
shoes and I know I know a lot of people
on the left think that that people in
business are very rapacious and people
in government are very kind but I look
around at the condition of the roads for
example in Los Angeles and I think about
the amount of money that's being spent
and it seemed to me that if these were
kind people
the roads are be in great shape and the
public sector retirement benefits would
be quite small and just to really
personalize that this tiny little road
that separates our two Studios is it
absolute dump its third world I needed
to dump the exit that we're off okay
here it is literally a dump time there's
garbage and my fiancee is shocked by it
because like everybody else in Russia
never was around the world for that
matter you grew up with America
America's the land where the streets are
paved with gold she sees all this
garbage on the streets in Los Angeles
and she's quite struck by it yeah it's
so interesting what you said a moment
ago about not respecting that vodka by
the way where there's a Russian theme
here they're sweet they're really but
it's not really us but at the fact that
you were pouring either way
there's a little thing about your hair
thank you very much that there is a
little endian aid in there though a
little one a little MDMA that's the
technical term for ecstasy is that right
yeah enjoy I like what you said there
that you were sort of even almost
accidentally in a way at first giving
conservatives an ability to be okay
because they had been under attack for
so long so that you gave them room to go
all right I'm not so bad or I'm strongly
not answer whatever it is and I think in
a weird way I've sort of maybe
accidentally partly and maybe not so
accidentally I've given liberals some
cover that are going wait a minute
something's wrong on the left and I've
just given them a little bit of room to
go it's okay to add some conversation so
I love that that we kind of from
different political places different
political homes the ideas of just
talking about ideas was was given some
room and as we said on my show I 100
percent certain that you and I could sit
down and over some more ecstasy water we
could probably we could probably write a
political platform that eighty-five
percent of the country good mind I
didn't solve we get behind eighty-five
percent of the people so so that's a
good segue to to cruise because I that
you were a cruise guy now I am I'm a
constitutional guy I want us to be
governed the way that the founding
fathers set up I believe in the branches
of government I don't like all the
executive actions people know my
thoughts on all of this stuff my feeling
with Cruz was there was something just
slimy about it that I couldn't and I
couldn't get over and I in retrospect
maybe I was wrong I don't know but I
couldn't get over that sort of used car
salesman thing with her with it with
with her with him
now ironically we have Trump now so it
is what it is but in terms Cruz you
basically your guy like that you thought
this is the guy that is defending all
the principles that I believe yeah
there's a lot very other on this very
quickly of one one of the reasons that I
was a Ted Cruz fan was because I met Ted
Cruz personally before I ever saw him on
TV and I remember very distinctly
thinking this guy this would be early
2010-11 something like this move I said
I don't know if this guy wants to be
President but he'll never do it because
he's just too nice
he's just way too nice for this and I
thought Crump said that everybody hated
him to the old Santa Teresa damn well I
had no doubt that they do but he's also
setting up for some principles and
that's not something Senate's known for
I guess about bandit hater you're
probably probably a good shave a butt
but I really like him very much and and
I had a couple of contacts from them
about helping a little bit with the
messaging on the campaign and and
essentially I said listen can we be
crystal clear on this I don't want to I
don't want to be helping to show you how
Ted Cruz should be acting on camera I
want to be showing you how to grow
should be not acting on camera please
please can we not just go out there to
his house and spend an hour with the
cameras rolling and get all the official
stuff out of the way and get down to the
guy who's actually there and but I hear
this for many many many people and I
never particularly I could see it
sometimes yeah I could see it and my
feeling was well you you got a run right
at this you don't run away from those
weaknesses you got to run right towards
it and get get in front of it explain it
but I liked I liked a lot about about
what Ted was sorry I have to tell you
the fact that Ted was born in Canada
bothered me enormous Lee I mean but and
this may be justification but I think
it's actual realistic justification not
to get too far on the weeds with this
but the requirement for the president
was a natural-born citizen and the
definition originally was that you would
be born in America exceptions were made
for people who were born before we
became independent for 50 60 years
the pitch had to be born in the United
States or United States territory of two
American parents and the reason was that
they did not want an undue influence on
you in regard to one of the countries
and and now having spent so much time
with somebody from Russia I certainly
see things about the Russia situation
that I'd never seen before I don't think
it would influence me and my ability to
make a decision but it certainly opened
up things there now what has absolutely
influenced me and prejudiced me I think
is a fair way to say it is that my mom
is a British subject and and I have a
very strong affinity to England my
grandfather was
order the British Empire and so so that
aspect of it does bias me and I can see
that that was a reasonable requirement
now Barack Obama was not there's no
discussion about I'm not going to get in
a little legality thing obviously but he
was not a natural-born citizen by the
definition of that because no one's
disputing that his father was Kenyan
when they ruled that this was
essentially okay when I said okay where
we he was not a natural-born citizen by
the by this genocide the strict
definition of it this the original
definition of it was to American parents
by the way I did a quick little thing
where I said let's imagine a four-way
race between Barack Obama Arnold
Schwarzenegger bill little and and Jesse
Jackson which one of these is qualified
to be President it's Jesse Jackson
Barack Obama has a Kenyan father I have
a British mother Schwarzenegger was born
outside the country according to the
strict definition of it now look it is
what it is but when a standard Falls
it's fallen
you can't unbreak it it sits down and
it's like the filibuster thing with the
nuclear option there was no Senate rules
about it it was it was comity which is
nowadays mostly comedy but everyone
thought it was manners it was a
gentleman's agreement it was it was
honor basically what it was yeah we
think it's important so this is a
tradition we've had for 150 200 years
whatever Harry Reid decides they need to
vote so he uses the Harry Reid option
and it's gone and I do have many
supporters who say well we can't play
that way we got to hold ourselves to a
higher standard my response to that is
no no you cannot do that once you have
to fight the way you're being fought and
if that's the rules that they want
that's the rules if they got and they're
going to regret it
so there are videos a hundred percent
when I was on The Young Turks a
progressive network at the time when
they pulled the the nuclear option
direction what that the read option yeah
okay so what Harry Reid did this and I
was saying that I was not for it because
you cannot change these rules and then
expect that it won't bite you in the ass
or something and I don't think they
expected it to bite them in the ass only
you know four years later or whatever
but yet you have to have principles yeah
it is hard to have principle yes a point
that's exactly right very everyone but
when we were talking so much about the
email situation in the insecure the
insecure server an en secures area is
it's pretentious machine really it
wasn't wasn't as beat up in old machine
as they couldn't was but but people
would say to me oh so you're telling me
that if Ted Cruz had done the same thing
you would you would you would have a
problem if Ted Cruz had done that I want
Ted Cruz in jail I'd want them in jail
more than I want her in jail these are
standards and these are principles and
these don't change now you may not agree
with them but they're consistent for me
and they're important and if it turns
out that somebody who I've been
supporting has been breaking the law I
want that person in jail I want them in
jail more than I want somebody on the
other side in jail so does this all feed
to why you were so happy in on election
night because of that as Andrew
described it the truck that ran through
the media or as I've described it the
the chess board that was thrown in the
air or whatever you were metaphor is
because when the Democrats do some of
this stuff like crushing iPads with
hammers and bleach bidding computers
things that the Clinton campaign did or
colluding with Donna Brazile which was
so obvious that it was going to happen I
had tweets about why you CNN hiring her
from back in 2013
I'm not Kreskin over here you know is
pretty obvious that these things were
happened so does that explain why you
were so happy that night because the
double standard categorically and that's
the only reason I was happy people that
I just I think we shouldn't diminish
that because it's so interesting you
were at a Trump guy I would suspect that
if you were if you're a real
constitutionalist as I expect you are
then you must have all sorts of fears
about Trump that he could you know take
too much power and too many executive
orders and look I'm not so much worried
about that to be honest with you my
primer my primary problems with Donald
Trump is I find him embarrassing there
are things he says and does that I find
embarrassing but that's the price that I
willingly and knowingly when and to and
was prepared to pay now for those people
to think that Oh everybody all the
conservatives are always complaining
about the media bias just as a quick
point in 2014 Evan Thomas when he was a
managing editor at Newsweek said that he
thought that press bias in 2004 I said
14 in 2004 he said he thought that press
bias for John Kerry and John Edwards was
worth 15 points at the poll
that's John Kerry that's not Barack
Obama is not Hillary Clinton so I took a
look at the Electoral College maps of
2008 2012 and 2016 I took 15 points away
from the Democrats and the entire
country is red Obama wins Delaware and
DC or something or he wins a why Hillary
Hillary wins Delaware it's all red all
of it and as I just as a rule of thumb
that's how the country would vote if the
media was unbiased now this needs to be
said because I never bring up the
subject without saying it many people
think that I want a conservative media I
don't want a conservative media I want a
fair media if we had a conservatively
biased media we would then fall into the
exact same errors that the left falls
into because we have the rim of
invisibility right there.ring your Star
Wars guy on a Star Trek guidebook
probably both love Lord of the Rings and
Andrew Craven pointed this out what what
the press bias does is it gives
Democratic politicians the ring of
invisibility they know they're not going
to get caught with and so when people
have a sense of invisibility they do
things that they would never do
otherwise and this is why when sometimes
in Mardi Gras or something like that
when people are wearing masks they'll
perform behaviors that would never ever
enter their minds because they don't
feel directly responsible and this is
the great failure of the modern age is
that I want a press that is looking 24
hours a day to find out whether there is
impeachable information on Donald Trump
I want them looking all the time
constantly to see if Donald Trump is
colluding with the Russians to see if
he's impeachable offenses are there but
I would also like that done for Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton and I don't
want them to suppress a story not just
not cover it just suppress it because
then you've got an autoimmune disease
David you know if it turns out that if
it turns out that the presses job is to
go through the human go through the
political bloodstream and and attack
pathogens and destroy them if it turns
out that it's not doing that but is in
fact a way that ideology and pathogens
are coming into this is nikkah countries
got aims at intellectual aids the
mechanism designed to defend us is now
the mechanism that is in fact bringing
in the the contagion is it too late to
fix that have we already crossed that
threat
shoulde I think you said I think I've
quoted you on the show actually you said
that night or maybe maybe ice and now
excited so many times I'm not sure who
said it but I own the credit port that
it got to parity that night but the
online media and the main Jam you got I
honestly can't remember which one of
another was a you I'll just you just
assume it was me all similar all right
very somebody in this room said that's
your dream and if I had said that
publicly I'm pretty sure credit anyway
I'd say for you clap but I think it's
probably just one of these convergent
thoughts you know where you realize that
something's happen so is it too late to
change it but there's good news and bad
news the good the bad news is is it too
late to change it yes yes the good news
is is it going to change yes and another
sounds paradoxical the mainstream media
and the entire media complex and all of
this is so heavily invested now there
pot committed Arian they've got to play
this card to the got to play the hand to
be to the end of the game and it is so
massive that you can't change it but the
good news is you don't have to because
for the first time it's not just our
civilizations collapse by the way I
started writing about the collapses of
civilization what kind of got me into it
is my love for history and I'll kept
wondering why do civilizations collapse
they there's a struggle struggle
struggle and when they finally reach
dominance you know when Rome finally
defeats Carthage and there's nothing
left and it should be pure off they go
they just collapse and I think they
collapse because the elites get bored
but that's the first time in history
when common people have had the means to
actually influence other common people
in large numbers and circumvent not just
the priesthood of the churches or the
media or the politicians we just talk
directly with each other and that I
think is our saving grace because now
there's a hundred and sixty million
people walking around with
high-definition television cameras in
their pockets they've also got news vans
in their pockets that were and that's a
big mass and a big radio because I can I
can Facebook live an event and now we're
in the world of absolute truth right
once we get video we're out of the world
of what you think of more I think there
it is
you know pics or it didn't happen right
I mean there it is
you can't you can't argue with seeing it
there is the inherent risk of that that
the system will have to fight back even
harder
HFS now I would know how to risk it
see inevitable consequence of yeah where
do you see that going because I do what
I do worry about that that it's a more
that people that you know I find that I
can get more honest conversation out
listening to you or listening to Joe
Rogan or Phil DeFranco or Sam Harris or
plenty of people that are you know
online people but and I turn on CNN I
mean I jokingly said to you in the green
room I put CNN on for you because I know
you love banner I got in there but I
watch it and it seems like pure dribble
eighteen heads all babbling on who got
everything wrong before the election now
telling you everything that's going to
happen six months from now and all of
this nonsense and it just seems it's
archaic in its whole machinery I mean
the amount of money that it costs
probably to do one night of Anderson
Cooper probably would foot the bill on
literally a year's worth of my show yeah
I don't think I'm being sarcastic so
what do you fear that monster sort of
hitting back in whatever that whatever
that means to you it's done the damage
it's going to do it's it's done the
maximum amount of damage it's going to
do the world is changing you can feel it
in them yeah taste it in the air or the
water whatever you had at the beginning
of the Lord of the Rings I got a chance
to meet a guy I like very much admire
very much in micro and I'd love to get
him out of show he's a wonderful man he
really is and um and he said I said I
saw one of these things that you just
did the way I heard it little he just
sets up a laptop in his in his kitchen
and he said the other thing got 7
million views or something when I was
doing deadliest jobs at the Senate
channel if I had 300,000 people watching
a show I'd get I'd get flowers from the
network yeah so here's why it may be
good to go back to what you started with
why why are things so acrimonious I
think they're so acrimonious now because
what what is what is not being seen
underneath all the Trump Obama trip
Obama Hillary blahblah underneath all of
this way underneath it is human beings
are going through something that that's
only ever happened twice before in all
of human history we we are straddling an
a worldwide fundamental change in how
the world is built you could make the
case with so many wars and empires and
governments and so on kings and so on
battles that the only things that have
really happened in history is the
invention of agriculture the Industrial
Revolution of the Information Age and
when we talk about things like our
cities being these murder pits it's not
an easy
to solve the reason the cities are
murder pits is because the jobs are
going the reason the jobs are going is
because America is now fully in the
Information Age and industrial era jobs
have gone to where they're less
expensive this is a fundamental problem
this is the same problem that farmers
had to face 400 years ago where farmers
were saying well we can't we can't feed
ourselves yeah you got to go work in a
factory in the city and they didn't want
to do that and and so it caused
tremendous upheaval but that's what
we're seeing it used to be that you
could that you could get off a boat and
walk through Ellis Island come out on
the other side and get a job in a
factory I mean no disrespect to factory
workers whatsoever but essentially an
assembly line job meant that your job is
to take this uh this this bolt and
tighten this bolt on in this location
and essentially anybody can do that
anybody so so industrial era jobs being
relatively repetitive gave people who
were hard-working and oftentimes very
smart but people who were new here
people who needed a chance to get
started gave them a chance to do some
work and get some decent jobs out of it
and Baltimore for example Baltimore for
a brief period there the neighborhoods
were they were integrated they were
there were people who'd been there for
quite a while a lot of a lot of black
workers coming up from the south after
the war but everybody was working at the
factory everybody's working hard
everybody had a vested interest in
making their yard look nice everybody
was going to more or less the same
church as they were hanging out together
didn't last very long but it was there
and it was there because because the
economic opportunities were there and
it's not like some company decided hey
you know what we make more money in
China that isn't that in fact what
happens but it's it's a fundamental
enormous enormous change and you can't
get people into the information economy
as easily as you could get them into the
industrial economy it's interesting to
me because we're obviously go under
going something absolutely massive right
and how addressable it's stressful yeah
it's stressful a lot of my direct
messages lately have been about that
stress just don't let politics make it
crazy try to escape and grieve every now
and again and do some stuff you enjoy
hopefully and whatever else but it also
shows why easy
Cirie's are never the correct answer
remember because I was in Seattle last
week and you know they've had this they
pushed for the $15 minimum wage all this
time and I cannot an economist but I
understand that I don't see why you
should be able to tell a private company
how much they should be able to pay
their employees blah blah blah I get off
the plane in Seattle and the McDonald's
in the Seattle Airport you know what
they have instead of workers I thought
about a kiosk a if iPad assuming I have
pretty soon we'll have hamburger flippin
machines yeah and that's because this is
I think this is the fundamental
difference between the two camps that we
call liberals and conservatives today
I'm sure that people going to find this
a self-serving explanation but
nevertheless here it is I believe that
liberals would rather feel good about
things even if they do harm and
conservatives would rather do things
that made sense even if it made them
look bad your example of the minimum
wage is a perfect example everybody
would like people to make $15 an hour
and and and it helped here we're free
I'd be in favor of free health care
right what kind of an animal would I be
no health care for you I don't like the
way you look your skin's a little dark
for me no health care for you I'll go
off and die in a ditch well I would be
the kind of person that people assume I
am if it were free but it's not free so
since it cost money we have to figure
out how to pay for it we have to figure
out how to pay for it means things like
competition all of a sudden you're
conservative again so this is the point
of it right it's it's you can feel good
about things because everybody else
tells you I'm in favor of I support but
I've got a bumper sticker on my Prius it
says Free Tibet see see how I like as I
care about Tibet and I'm deeply
concerned about the about the about the
people of Tibet and I don't doubt that
they are but if you want a free to bed
you need a bumper sticker that says the
United States Marine Corps right or a
National Rifle Association or something
like that because that's what it would
take to actually free Tibet and that's
not a pleasant thought and nobody likes
to admit it and if you had somebody say
that you'd get a lot of grief for it but
it's the reality of the world and so
sugarcoating sugarcoating the outcome in
order to preserve this sense of this
warm fuzzy feeling I have about myself
to me is a form
of vanity and and hypocrisy that I can't
afford for myself anymore what we just
as a society it seems to me we don't
have time for it anymore because of the
change that we're going under right now
there is no time to fiddle around with
these feeling things when we're in such
a massive time of upheaval right and
we're in and we're in this enormous of
people here I think this is probably the
best way to think about it why are
people becoming so it why are the why
are the sides diverging so much why is
it the county but we're not even looking
at the same news stories anymore why is
it that half the country thinks that
Donald Trump should be impeached
immediately the other half says that
CNN's already admitted there's nothing
to this story why why can't it be two
sides hear each other and you know the
the word mean before the fort medic at
would you know impact not at the bottom
of it
Amin was it was the idea that a thought
could be transmitted the same way as a
gene could it could be passed on
essentially so I think you can get a
pretty good analogy out of genetics on
this if you have a population that lives
here and a significant number of people
move over there and now there's a
mountain range between them something
happens when everybody's living together
everybody inter marries and so they said
they share the exact same gene pool when
people go over to a second location now
these people have the same gene pool is
these people but if they are no longer
in a mingling with each other the normal
evolution that this group has isn't
affected by these guys these guys have a
whole nother set of evolution and what
you find is is you find this genetic
diversion and they'll continue to divert
it will divert until they become
different species because they're
because the genes are not communicating
we're over here evolving they're over
here evolving and this split is
irrevocable unless you can remix the
populations I think it's the same thing
with means we basically here as
conservatives we hear news with your
stories we are interpretations all of it
that has become part of our mimetic code
and liberals have a mimetic code too and
we're getting very close to the point
now where these two things Candida breed
anymore you know it comes a point when
the species diverged enough so that
that's the definition of a species is
one that you no longer interbreed with
the other right and this is
that this is bad bad bad because even
though this divergence is happening so
much we're living next to each other you
know these are not continents that are
that are going their separate ways we're
literally living there we in fact I'm in
the same room and yet here we are right
enough here we are the divergence is
essentially nothing it's it's
essentially nothing it's 10 percent 15
percent you know that's the part that I
want to start focusing on and I think
maybe for the next year the show because
I sense the things are going to keep
going like this
I'm going to try I think that's what
I've been trying to do anyway but maybe
focus a little more on that 10 or 15
percent because most of us want the same
simple thing if you know whether we I
suppose you're pro-life right you know
it's funny
of all the things I am I was trying to
pick me I am but of all of the things in
my in my toolbox that is the one that's
the most precarious that's so
interesting to me because I'm pro-choice
and I would say it with the most
begrudging unpleasant I just see no
option in this case that I you know we
can talk about how many months or you
know if you're going to nah let somebody
have an abortion at some point then does
the state have to get involved all
that's up but but even that that proves
the 10% right there right you're saying
I begrudge me come to this or this I
have like I have fun I think the reason
the abortion issue is such a hot issue
and the reason that so many people do
that split go all the way to one slider
all the way to other because it does in
fact it leaves you without there's no
middle ground here mmm
and and so you have to pick one and if
both sides of the argument make sense to
you because they do then you have to
decide which one has the greater weight
right and I don't have the religious
belief that some people do that that
drives them to be very very passionate
about this and nor do I have the
complete lack of religious belief that
drives other people to be in the other
position this one is a tough one the
reason I come down on the pro-life side
is essentially pretty simple people say
this is my body I should be able to
right to control my own body and I say
you have 100% agree with that but it's
not your body if this this is different
this is an entirely different
chromosomal pattern you could take a
sample from the mother and a sample from
the infant and you would get two
completely different people so
frankly look the abortion issue is very
simple it can be solved in one sentence
and won't be resolved in one sentence
but it could be you put all the
advertising terms away pro-life
Pritchard put all that stuff away what
it comes down to is is it a person yes
or no from conception to birth is it a
person if it's not a person then who the
hell are you to tell me what to do with
with my bodily functions if it is a
person then it has protections that
supersede somebody else's opinion about
it and that's where the entire heart of
the issue is is it a person or not and
the reason this thing is so bloody hard
is because there from conception to
birth there is no single day or event
that happens there's no switch there's
no there's no mile-marker that gets
passed it is a perfect spectrum of
absolutely uniformity between the cell
that splits in half and a little baby
that comes crying into the world and
this is why this issues such a bear
right and that's why so some people will
argue well from conception its life and
then some people argue well at eight
months you should still be allowed to
have an abortion I would say both of
those are not great really tenable
position but then you know you can you
can whittle this no pun intended that
all the time you must hear that means I
think like almost almost I did it like
17 times gladly but but I would say that
may be all right if we could whatever
science could get us to where we'd say
all right for the first three months you
can have an abortion again not because
you love abortion I just want to have an
abortion but we were drugging lee allow
for this tandem and I know women I know
two women in the last year that had
abortions who did not do it lightly and
then but what a terrible position to
have to be put in even if categorically
yeah but but that's say okay well for
the first three months you can have
motion but then if the government then
says alright but if the magic moment
whatever you want to call it is three
months well now does and we're not going
to let you have an abortion does the
state now have a responsibility now as a
small government guy and more of a
libertarian you probably don't want the
state to have responsibly but at the
same time if the state is saying you got
to do it then do we have responsibility
I would probably argue yes again but
grudgingly so that's why it's but it's a
rich place to have a conversation which
conversation tragic conversation there's
nobody in this discussion who's happy
about this no one's going to Lulu no no
I had an interesting thought about the
abortion issue because
it got to me the question of the whole
person issue and maybe this will help
people who are who are who are on the
pro-choice side understand the pro-life
position at least understand it and if
not agree with it does certainly not
expect them to agree with it at least
understand it and and my position my
thought experiment was this whose side
were you on in the civil war that most
people hated or as was I 100% now the
South claims that the North launched
this war of aggression because they
wanted to secede in state rights and all
that but the reason the South left the
Union was they wanted the states rights
and the state right was the state right
to have slaves so let's just call it
what it is they left before link it was
even inaugurated if you're a southerner
your position was this is my property
and they're going to launch a war and
come all the way down to my house and
take my property then of course it's
aggression of course I'm going to fight
it right the North's position is the
same position actually as the pro-life
crowd which is that is a living person
there and you do not own them and you do
not have a right to determine their
destiny therefore we have a right to go
down and free the slaves we have but not
only a right we have an obligation and
so now what you find out is that the
motivation of the civil war comes down
to a very simple issue our slaves people
yes or no because if slaves are not
people if blacks from Africa are not
people they're not humans then they're
property like horses and cattle and so
on the north is absolutely wrong the war
is completely unjust and so on but if
they are people then the North has the
moral right and the obligation to have
the government step in on that person's
individual choice and protect that
individual that's the fundamentals of
the pro-life position is that it is not
it is it has its own unique genetic code
it cannot defend itself it is no longer
subject to your choice it's a person and
when we're going to think we're going to
protect it is it a person isn't it how
do I know yeah we know conception when
we know birth and that's all and because
the spectrum is uninterrupted we find
ourselves in this horrible conundrum
which puts me against my desire to
protect innocent
I can't defend themselves against the
disgusting repulsive idea that any
institution including the government
gets to tell you what to do and when to
do it yeah and that's why it's such a
rich one to talk about where where you
can sit across from somebody and
hopefully not impugn their every motive
right right and this is where the
problem is right everybody automatically
demonizes the other side automatically
assumes they're evil I suppose I've been
guilty about to some degree I try to
focus that kind of vitriol on people who
I am convinced are aware of what they're
doing yeah you know not just people most
all virtually all liberals well I think
many liberal policies I consider to be
very poor and some of them I consider to
be downright evil but I will certainly
grant it the huge majority of people who
support these policies do so for
fundamentally good reasons they think
it's the best way to help people they
think it's the kind thing to do they
think it's the nice thing to do I don't
question their motives but the people
that are enforcing these policies know
what the consequences are in the real
world and those people have a problem so
marks that you absolutely can't make
you're pretty good if I hope I'm not
going in the water here I'm like a cam
you know it's interesting I would be
remiss if I didn't say in the course of
all this a few times you've said
liberals and conservatives I think you
know I consider myself a classical
liberal so just for the sake of argument
when you say liberal really you're
talking about sort of a leftist or a
progressive yes sir I hate to get lost
no no no a label is everything important
I know people will be commenting going
to the connemara team talking about
liberal not know critically important I
meant to say progressives I usually do
here's the irony of it you you call
yourself a traditional liberal and I
call myself a conservative and what I'm
trying to conserve is liberal principles
I'm trying to conserve liberal
principles people think what when people
were being held as slaves I'm a liberal
when women are deprived from holding
office or deprived from from jobs at you
know the same panic I'm a liberal
liberal on all these things but when I
become a conservative is when this
situation has gone too far you what do
you mean by too far when equality of
opportunity and equality under the law
and and when Martin Luther King says
I have a dream that my children will be
judged by not by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
I'm a big old liberal when it comes to
that but when you get to a place where
then you say things like wait that black
people can't be racist or that that we
need set asides or that we should hold
people to a lower standard or whatever
you've gone too far now I want to
conserve these principles I want to
conserve traditional liberalism
classical liberalism is not as what many
people on the far left would not agree
with today what I know and free speech
is number one right for free speech
number one the fundamental idea of
classical liberalism is I should be able
to say whatever I dev will want to you
should be able to say whatever you demo
want to and you hurting my feelings is
not the same as assaulting me physically
it's my feelings getting hurt by you is
my problem not your problem and this is
a traditional core value of liberalism
which conservatives are trying to
conserve in the face of these
progressives who want people to shut up
and if they don't agree with them then
they hit them on the head with a tire
lock yeah and that's why I've said
defending my liberal positions is
becoming a conservative principle it's
destiny there we go so there it is so
most everything most everything I think
on the table politically could be
resolved amicably with things like
perhaps abortion being a real sticking
point emotionally but most things could
be I think resolved pretty amicably one
little example I was up in Idaho and I
was talking to some some people there
and it looks like they may be able to do
things as a state that we can't do as a
federal government and I said you know
guys if you could just explain the
Laffer curve you'd get what we want and
the and the progressives would get what
they want to if we could just show the
mat that shows that there comes a point
as you lower the tax burden the economy
grows at such a rate that by lowering
taxes you increase revenue
who loses here businessmen and and
people like me and conservatives want
lower taxes so we can do more we can
expand more we can do and do all these
other things but if it turns out that
lowering taxes increases revenues and
you're against that that's where I go
with these things I try to go to the
moral argument why do you need more
people so much Democrats what do you
mean well your taxes are so high that
you're not getting maximum revenues out
of this economy so if you actually
genuinely do
you wanted to help poor people and
disadvantaged people you need money to
do it then you should be in favor of
something that brings in more revenues
and if you're saying no I'd rather let
those people undergo some hardships so
long as the rich get whacked now you
don't have the fig leaf anymore now you
don't get to say oh I'm doing this for
somebody else you're doing it out of a
sense of envy and and other vino writers
I suspect usually though that their
argument be well we want to take from
these people so that they can't get too
much so that we can you know they have
another justification for it I don't
agree with that justification this is
one of the instances taxes what I
definitely shifted a little right in the
last couple years but I see what your
point taxes
look this is not a inflammatory
statement taxes or money that are taken
from individuals at a rate determined by
somebody else and enforce by law I think
we can all agree on that's a relatively
fair assessment of it so so if your
position is as some people have too much
and other people don't have enough I
understand that position I understand it
I sympathize with the would-be end
results that you're looking for but if
it turns out that your personal
animosity and your personal commitment
here's the thing if you really believe
that and it could be shown that lowering
taxes increases state revenue than
anybody that's not in favor of that is
not talking about benefits for the poor
they're talking about their own envy
they're talking about their own
inability to take your eyes off of what
somebody else is making right and
there's no end point I mean there's no
point where you are we've taken enough
now we can change the item and do it
more equitably right or so so you know
we hear you could take a look at if you
look at if you look at education scores
versus money what you find is the more
money we've spent the worse our scores
of gotten right and it's all the
arguments always the same we need more
money for schools well we pay three or
four times per student per student more
than the next closest developed country
and our grades are 27th 28th 29th people
like me would look at this and say it's
not a question of more money the more
money we put in the lower our result
gets I would look at it and say the
problem with education today is we're
getting what we're paying for and we're
not paying for education we're paying
for graduation and these are separate
things we have a factory where these
boxes we get paid by the box that comes
out of the
we wine and it doesn't matter if the
product in the box is a terrific product
or if it's broken or it is nothing in
the box we get paid by the bar right so
that's what we're paying for and that's
what we're going to get but if we
decided we wanted to start paying for
education instead of graduation we'd see
a whole different set of incentives and
then people would do what I think they
normally do which is pursue their best
in self-interest with in virtually
everybody a sense of understanding that
I'm not the only person in this entire
country I have obligations to other
people for decency and so on do you
think people might be fundamentally
decent I know for an absolute certain
fact that if you and I were to pick
where to pick any ten people from your
audience of ten people from my audience
and put them in the same room I would
bet you it would take us less than three
hours to get people to agree that all
they say kind of done yeah
well twenty twenty twenty twenty three
of us twenty two of us could write up
could write a plan for that that we
would in if we could get past the
animosity we would find here secure so
in a nutshell here's the way I think it
works liberals have a desire to protect
people who are who are underprivileged
conservatives
say yes but the way to do that is is
through this mechanism and this is where
that is where the head go button goes
this way I personally am so offended by
the racist charge in the massagers
charge and the hateful charge in the
Nazi charge because it's not about I
don't care about them I just want as
much as I can get for me it turns out
that the way the world is built the way
human nature is built is that by me
getting as much as I can for me is in
fact the best way for these people to be
helped this is the this is the this is a
difference between feeling good and
seeing what seems to be right many looks
if handing poor people money stop them
from being poor we wouldn't have four
people we wouldn't have poverty in this
country said trillions and trillions of
dollars have been paid and we're not
getting anywhere so it's not that so if
it's not that then what is it yeah
right well we've done over an hour here
now that I know our suitors are so close
I suspect we will do this again we'll
set up a couple hands with a strap we do
we literally could have better audio
quality than I have at my studio that is
that close but I want to ask you one
thing I didn't say the two words common
sense or you walked out of here I'd feel
bad because your book was the common
sense resistance it's the phrase that
your your tag on your website and common
sense I think nothing that we've done
here I think that for the most part what
I've consistently tried to do every week
is just bring a little common sense
sometimes I talk with pretty bright
people who are doing a a really high
level stuff that goes above that pay
grade but that's the basics of what most
people want right now are common sense
so to wrap this all a nice little bow
what is the best way to just bring a
little more common sense into the world
right now I think common sense is
derided by people who have a vested
interest in telling themselves how
important an we don't add it for content
no and the reason I know this is because
I was one of those people myself you
know if life was a role-playing game I
put all my points into intelligence I
just had to show everybody how smart it
was intelligence was everything
everything everything you care about
anything else but the problem with that
is it makes you think that because
you're smarter than people in some area
that you're smarter than people in all
areas and that's just not true if you
were to take I would suspect that most
progressives would think that the way to
handle something like the economy would
take the twenty brightest Harvard Yale
economist put them in a room have them
set policy and then this policy would be
determined across the country legally
enforced and that this would be the
smartest way to handle it because
they're smarter than the guy that runs a
gas station on the corner of the street
there's no question that they're more
intelligent and the guy that runs the
corner gas station but what they don't
know more about is how to run a corner
gas station and that's what they don't
know more about and the idea that we are
going to take away from the person who
runs the gas station the decisions on
how to run a gas station is where we get
into trouble just because you're smarter
than people in some areas doesn't mean
you're smarter than people in all areas
and kind of takes us back to that Junior
samples moment I had where I thought
well you know what a what a what a
cartoon of a you know
a rube and then some grace I was just
lightning bolted into a realization of
how repugnant that is and how much more
this man must know about many many
things than I do once you understand
that you realize that you can't take ten
or twenty processors no matter how fast
they are and process information faster
than you can with 320 million processors
working in local information in parallel
all of them and and so I think the main
thing to do would be to get away from
this sense of is to get away from the
sense that this country consists of
smart people and dumb people and that
the dumb people vote for Donald Trump
and that they don't ceiling of it the
best thing I ever heard about Donald
Trump that goes to this common-sense
thing is I'm sure you've heard this
before so the difference between
progressives and conservatives is that
progressives take Trump literally but
they don't take him seriously while
conservatives taken seriously but they
don't take it literally and that's
really it we know I know and most of us
know what he is this we tried a nice guy
we tried a couple of nice guys Mitt
Romney's probably the most decent men
never walked this earth in politics he's
a racist he's a murderer Easy's he's
giving people cancer he's sucking with
the health care okay okay I don't mind
if you want you want a nice fighter
you're going to get a nice fighter and
and so we can all walk it down and the
main reason I was so happy about coming
to do this was I knew this is what this
conversation was going to turn into it
was going to be an example the people
may have different labels in fact agree
on virtually everything and I think they
don't agree on are things that they can
agree to disagree on I'm going to go
home and think about some of these
things probably in a way I hadn't before
and at the very least if you can't come
to agreement on this then you can at
least understand that the person who
you're disagreeing with is not some kind
of monster that's the essence of common
sense to me it's built into the society
it's baked in it's a texture that's
baked on the wall and we we we sneer at
that at our peril well let's keep this
conversation go and I'd be delighted
we will meet privately at that
restaurant I mentioned like a lot of fun
now
the exit that's a dumb that I both
probably have to figure out in our now
fortune fortune now very which had now
society that we don't have don't be a
theory and there's a good restaurant
within okay and fortune lets a whole
nother discussion but yeah they could
say it was a good restaurant it's just
arrests not its poor channel have this
edge run for Senate all right all right
for more on bill check out bill Whittle
[Music]
you